ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Recently, the Huberman
Lab hosted a live event
at the Beacon Theater
in New York City.
The event was entitled,
"The Brain-Body Contract,"
and it consisted of
a lecture followed
by a question and answer
session with the audience.
We wanted to make the recorded
version of that question
and answer session
available to everybody,
regardless of who could attend.
So what follows is the
question and answer
period from the Brain-Body
Contract live Huberman Lab
event.
Want to be sure to thank the
sponsors from that event.
They were Eight
Sleep, which makes
smart mattress covers with
heating and cooling capacity.
I started sleeping on
an Eight Sleep mattress
cover about eight months
ago, and it has completely
transformed my sleep.
I sleep so much deeper.
I wake up far less during the
middle of the night, if at all,
and I wake up feeling far
better than I ever have,
even after the same
amount of sleep.
In fact, I love my Eight Sleep
so much that when I travel--
now, I'm quite bothered that
Airbnbs and hotels don't
have Eight Sleep
mattress covers on them,
and I've even shipped my
Eight Sleep mattress cover out
to meet me in the location
that I arrived to so that I
get the best possible sleep.
If you want to try
Eight Sleep, you can go
to eightsleep.com/huberman to
save up to $400 off their Sleep
Fit Holiday Bundle, which
includes their new Pod 3 Cover.
Eight Sleep currently
ships in the USA,
Canada, United Kingdom,
select countries in the EU,
and Australia.
Again, that's
eightsleep.com/huberman.
I'd like to also thank our
supplement partner, Momentous.
They make the very highest
quality supplements.
They ship internationally, and
they formulated supplements
as single-ingredient
formulations
that match what is discussed
on the Huberman Lab podcast.
If you're interested in
any of those supplements,
please go to
livemomentous.com/Huberman.
And now, without further ado,
the question and answer session
from the live event held
at the Beacon Theater
in New York City.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You've said before that
stress can be good for us,
but how do we know
when it's too much?
That's a good question,
and I should preface that
by saying that there's
some incredible work that
was done by a colleague
of mine, Dr. Alia Crum.
Ali is how she goes
by, Dr. Allie Crum.
Who is a-- she was a
Division I athlete.
She's a tenured professor
of psychology at Stanford.
She's a licensed clinical
psychologist, like everyone.
So when I look
around my colleague,
I'm like, oh, my goodness.
Who are these people?
Very humbling place to be.
But she's made some
important discoveries,
and I want to just
highlight one, which
is this notion of mindset.
And no, these are
not placebo effects,
but let me just tell you.
When you think about stress,
how you think about stress
is really important.
First of all, you
can't lie to yourself.
But if for instance you watch
a one or three-minute video,
as she's given subjects
in her lab about stress,
and it tells you all
the terrible things
that stress does to your
immune system and sleep,
then you experience
those things-- increases
in blood pressure, et cetera.
However, if you watch a one
to three-minute video that's
also true about the fact
that stress can sharpen
your decision making for
certain kinds of things,
actually, can accentuate
your immune system.
I wish someone had helped me get
this narrative right out there.
Stress does not deplete
your immune system,
unless it goes on
a long, long time.
We'll talk about what
long means in a moment.
Why would it?
Think about it.
If you had to fast
and move with family
or weather a storm of any
kind, emotional or physical,
and you got sick, that
wouldn't make any sense.
It's usually after
you're stressed.
If you've ever been go, go, go,
or taking care of a loved one
or studying or working hard,
and then you finally go
on vacation, you rest, you
arrive, and you get sick,
it's because your
immune system shut down.
It stopped.
Your immune system is mobilized
by that alertness side
of your autonomic nervous
system, but you do need sleep.
You do need sleep,
and it's actually,
we think, the slowing
of circulation.
And this is why it's
probably not a good idea
to exercise if
you're already sick,
and if you're
veering towards sick
probably limit the intensity
of any kind of interaction
as best you can and
just still yourself.
Well, Ali's lab has clearly
shown us over and over again
that what we know, our
knowledge base, really
does shape the physiology
over those outcomes.
Now, you know that stress
is both bad and good,
so which one is it?
Does it average to nothing?
No.
It turns out that
you can bias this
in one direction or the other,
depending on which information
you're listening to more often.
I think this is
really important.
I still am trying to
get my head and my mind
around what's happened
over the last few years
and where it's placed us.
Like where did it land us?
Are we more resilient now, or
are we just really beat up?
I don't know.
I really don't know,
but I think how
we interpret the
last few years is
going to make a big difference
in terms of how it impacts us.
How do we know if we are--
thanks, yeah.
What we're missing
out there, I think,
is a narrative from somebody
that people listen to.
And I'm not saying that
person should be me.
In fact, it shouldn't be me but
somebody that can help us frame
what's just happened to
us, much like a good--
I think the world needs a
good therapist, basically.
Needs a very good therapist.
So I would call
short-term stress, which
is very beneficial for us,
is the kind of stress that
happens on the order of a
day, two, or three days.
Not a problem.
Even if you feel torn
apart, provided you can get
rest afterwards.
Long-term stress is
the kind of stress
that really starts to impede
your sleep-wake cycle,
make your dreams more stressful
and more like nightmares,
and they're not going away.
And I can promise you
that for those of you that
have challenges with
accumulation of stress
from the past that's now
compounded by what's happening
now, et cetera,
the solution does
seem to be to get yourself
into a supported environment
of some kind that will allow you
to go through a full catharsis.
Again, it doesn't have
to require psychedelics.
That can take you
through the full ride
of autonomic intensity--
catharsis of some sort--
and then relaxation.
That does seem to be
what snaps people out
of what we would call
longer term stress
and historical stress.
There's even the question
of whether or not
focusing directly on the trauma
and the story is so critical.
I think it is.
Obviously that's
something that should
be done with a
clinician, but stress
that impedes your sleep for
three nights or more, that
shifts the pattern of dreams
to more anxious dreams, that
is more long-term stress.
And for that, you need
to take it seriously,
and it's the kind of thing where
if you don't take it seriously,
it can start degrading things
like your immune system,
et cetera.
And I would say that
under those conditions,
use sleep as a good marker.
In fact, I'm sure there are
some clinicians in the room.
I mean, one of the questions
that is used as a diagnostic
for whether or not
people are depressed
or anxiously depressed
is whether or not
they are sleeping well or not.
Again, language is not
very good at parsing
what's going on inside.
We have to look to
behaviors and regularity
of sleep-wake cycles, et cetera.
Hopefully that was at
least a partial answer.
I tried to be accurate,
but if I were exhaustive,
I might actually
cure insomnia someday
with these podcasts
if nothing else.
How has hypnosis been
impacting my life?
I'm in hypnosis.
No, the-- I actually spent most
of the afternoon in hypnosis.
Before I do these, I spend
a good hour in hypnosis.
Again, self-directed hypnosis--
gosh, it's so unfortunate.
I keep talking to David
Spiegel about this.
Again, his dad was
one of the originators
of hypnosis as a valid
psychiatric treatment.
There's even the
idea that things
like EMDR, the scanning
of eyes back and forth
while reporting a
narrative, may actually
be capturing some of the
elements of hypnosis.
Again-- and this is
why, at least for me,
I appreciate the opportunity
to come together tonight
to talk about principles.
I would hope that
after tonight, you
could look at any
practice, anything,
any compound, any
breathing exercise,
and just be able
to frame up which
continuum, where
on the continuum,
what's it really designed to do.
Move you up towards alertness
or down towards calm.
And in fact, because
I can't help myself,
I'll just tell you for
all the breathing stuff,
it can be made very simple.
If your exhales
are longer and more
vigorous than your inhales,
you're going to get calm down.
If your inhales
are longer and more
vigorous than your
exhales, you're
going to become more alert.
And if you hold your
breath, just eventually
just start breathing again.
The physiology maps
perfectly to that.
That maps perfectly
to the physiology.
And if, for instance, you do
box breathing-- inhale hold,
exhale holding, and
this kind of thing--
well, you're going to stay
right where you're at.
You're going to be on an
even plane more or less.
So that hopefully captures all
of breathwork in one sentence.
Now, I'll answer the
question you were asking me.
Hypnosis, it's impact in my
life in a couple of ways.
One way is more from a
practical scientific way, which
is that my laboratory works on
vision, and we work on stress.
And in some ways, those
might seem divorced.
Although now with the
cuttlefish and the fact
that your eyes narrow
their field of view
when you're stressed,
et cetera, it
should become
obvious why that is.
But hypnosis also
takes advantage
of this really weird
cool feature, which is--
and it's always weird when
you do a group exercise,
but I can't really
see you all that well.
I certainly can't see your
eyes well enough to know this.
But David Spiegel, there's
actually something in the--
this is a valid thing called
the Spiegel Eye Roll Test,
and it's not the
teenage eye roll.
That when you look up while
not moving your head-- when
you look up, you
actually are engaging
circuits in your brainstem
that are involved
in generating alertness.
And when you look down
and your eyes close,
the opposite is true.
You're engaging circuits in
the brain that are taking you
into a calmer state.
Now, wouldn't it be wonderful if
all you had to do was look down
and you'd be calm and look
up and you'd be alert.
That doesn't quite
work that way.
But to induce
hypnosis, what they do
is they have people look up,
and then while looking up,
close their eyes, which
is actually hard to do.
Some people can't do it.
Their eyes roll forward, hence
the Spiegel Eye Roll Test.
Some people, their
eyes get-- you
see the whites of their eyes,
and it looks really spooky,
and they're looking up
while their eyes closed.
Those people are very
prone to hypnosis.
Why?
Well hypnosis is a
state of deep relaxation
with alertness and focus.
It's a contextual
narrowing-- excuse me.
So it's like being
in early stage sleep,
and that's why stage hypnosis
works with telling people
to do certain things.
It's not that they
don't care or they're
under the control
of the hypnotist.
It's that they forget
what's around them.
Why?
Because their mind is focused
internally and on the dialogue
with the hypnotist and is not
paying attention to context.
So it's a narrowing of context.
But hypnosis for me has
been very useful because A,
it validated the relationship
between vision and states
of mind.
It also checks off
this box, again,
which is that to
access neuroplasticity,
what do you need?
You need focus plus you need
a state of deep relaxation.
Usually, first focus then
sleep or non-sleep deep rest.
But Spiegel and his
daddy figured out
because they're way smarter than
I am that you can get people
into that perfect state
of neuroplasticity
by combining them
both in real time
through this atypical
thing we call hypnosis.
So I do daily or maybe every
other day hypnosis script
that's about-- it's
self-directed hypnosis
script of about 5 to
15 minutes, usually,
trying to get myself to be
less pissed off about something
that I'm really pissed
off about, frankly.
I imagine the stuff
I'm really pissed off
about in the screen
on the left side.
I think about all the things
that make me feel good,
and then I keep thinking
about how angry I am.
This is really how it goes.
And then over time,
I've noticed, well,
you're coupling that
bodily state of calm
to the anger thing.
This is all very hard
to do in talk therapy.
No disrespect to talk therapy.
There's a tremendous advantage
to talk therapy that I myself
have benefited from
it, although according
to certain people in
my life not enough.
But hypnosis works
because it's capturing
neuroplasticity processes.
Thank you for that question.
What are the most
effective protocols
for boosting the microbiome?
Oh.
Well, here, I'm very
fortunate because my upstairs
neighbor at Stanford is the
great Justin Sonnenburg,
and he and his wife Erika
run this amazing lab defining
all the principles of
the gut microbiome,
and they have a
really cool idea.
I don't know if he's
serious about this,
but I can't help
but chuckle when
I think that this
might actually be true.
We all know-- this
is definitely true--
that we all carry
around trillions
of little micro-bacteria.
Not just in our gut--
that goes from one
end of our throat
to the other-- any
mucosal lining.
Eyes, genitalia, nose--
we have microbiomes
in our nose, et cetera.
This is why we're heading
into the winter months
being a nasal breather.
That sounds like crazy new agey
stuff-- be a nasal breather.
There's actually a book written
by Paul Ehrlich and Sandra Kahn
at Stanford with a foreword
by Jared Diamond and Robert
Sapolsky.
The book, Jaws, so these
are some heavy hitters.
And there's very good evidence
that people who mouth breathe
are making themselves
more prone to illness
when nasal breathing
because of the microbiome.
It's just a better
filter for germs.
So this winter and always really
try and be a nasal breather
all the time.
One of the best ways to do that
if you're not into the mouth
taping thing,
which people do, is
to try and do some
of your exercise
with just nasal breathing.
It'll take a little
while to get used to,
but I'm not good at the
nasal breathing thing
because I'm always talking.
The microbiome is all
over us and in us.
It's on our skin.
We're actually exchanging
it when we meet
and we shake hands.
Do you know what happens usually
in the first 10, 15 seconds?
Data from Noam Sobel's
lab at the Weizmann
has shown that we wipe our eyes.
We wipe other people's
molecules on us.
We're really good at that.
Just watch these interactions.
Now, everyone's going be
doing the germ free handshake.
They're going to be fist bump.
But there is this idea that
maybe we are the house cats.
Maybe we're not
just transporting
all these microbiota
because it's good for us.
What if we're just the vehicles,
and they're running the planet?
And they're like, oh, we're
running out of some stuff.
Like we should figure out
somebody to take us to Mars,
and then we'll take over Mars.
I mean, maybe it's all them.
And Justin was the
one that told me that,
and I was like, that's kind of
eerie if you think about it.
But there might be these
other intelligences that
are hijacking us,
and that's scary
because we like to think that
we're in charge, and who knows.
What's good for your microbiome,
or what's good for them
that is?
Well, prebiotic fiber
seems to be very important,
but the studies of
fiber, at least,
as it relates to the microbiome
are somewhat controversial.
There was a study done
on humans at Stanford
by Chris Gardner and
Justin Sonnenburg
that showed that people
who eat one to four--
you have to ramp up--
servings of low sugar
fermented foods.
This would be your kimchi,
your natos, your sauerkraut,
your kiefer's, your
kombuchas, et cetera.
Per day develop a very
robust microbiome,
and fiber did not do that.
In fact, fiber increased
the so-called inflammatory,
which is the markers
for inflammation,
but that doesn't mean
that fiber is bad.
Fiber actually is--
getting enough fiber
is correlated with a
number of other things
that are great, like reduced
cardiovascular disease,
for instance, cancers of
the colon, for instance--
so fiber and gut microbiota.
Prebiotics, probiotics,
probably only necessary
if you have a dysbiosis-- if
you've been taking antibiotics,
or if for some reason you're
depleted of the microbiome.
One of the great ways to
deplete your microbiome
is to just eat highly
processed foods,
but hopefully most
people aren't doing that.
So prebiotic fiber and these
low-sugar fermented foods,
and then someone
always says beer.
So and always, yes.
Yes, beer will support
your microbiome,
but it might do
other things too.
So in general, low-alcohol,
low-sugar fermented foods
reduce the number of
inflammatory markers.
That's very, very clear
from the Sonnenburg data.
And then there are
other ways, of course.
The microbiome, actually,
interacts with temperature.
So the cold exposure
thing is actually
good for your microbiome, but--
and I want to really
emphasize this.
If you hear about studies
that such and such improves
such and such, keep
in mind that anything
that improves your
sleep, your microbiome,
or your social
interactions will improve
basically everything else.
And those are what we call
modulating-- excuse me--
effects, not mediating effects.
This is really important, and
we teach first year graduate
students and medical
students about this.
Like for instance, if there were
a fire alarm pulled right now--
God forbid-- it would modulate
all of your attention,
but would you say that fire
alarms mediate Attention No.
It's not directly in
the line of mechanism,
but it can adjust an
existing mechanism.
So great sleep is
great for everything,
but it doesn't
control it directly.
And so things like
getting great sleep,
keeping your microbiome healthy,
getting enough sunlight,
et cetera-- they provide
a kind of buoyancy
to all the organs and
systems of your body,
but they aren't necessarily
the thing that cures ADHD.
But of course, if you have
ADHD or issues with focus,
getting enough sleep will help.
Is nutrition the way
to cure your ADHD?
No, but if you improve
your gut microbiome,
it's very likely that your
neurotransmitter systems
will improve.
Limiting sugar will help,
et cetera, et cetera.
So there's reason to think that
great sleep, solid nutrition,
microbiome, social
interactions, exercise--
those are the big five.
There are others too, of course.
With those you set
a good buoyancy
to all the other
systems, and then we
get into the things of
how to directly increase
focus or modulate dopamine
and so on and so forth.
Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I realize some
people are afraid of dogs.
We actually have a dog
stimulus in our fear lab.
We get people that
are terrified of dogs.
We hired this dog
trainer guy who
has these pit bulls that will
attack you while you're in VR.
By the end, people are a
little more comfortable
with dogs in general.
For you and me, if you're
not afraid of dogs,
that's not terribly terrifying.
But if you are, even
the thought of that
can be pretty terrifying.
A couple of things-- people have
thought about the eye contact
thing.
They make eye contact.
We're big on eye contact.
Humans too.
Eye contact is meaningful in
terms of oxytocin release.
That's all real.
Those data are-- the
more and more data
that come out from better
studies-- eye contact is
a big deal.
I think it's also that
just the dogs are always
game to show up exactly
where you want to meet them,
and they always show up in
their most loving possible state
for them.
It's a pretty simple
equation if you get it right.
They need proper care, but--
I mean, Costello was unique
because the bulldog also--
you don't want to get
me going on dog breeds,
but the bulldog also looks
disappointed all the time.
And then you do
something it likes,
and then it looks delighted,
and pretty soon you're
working for their approval.
And we were like
the odd couple--
me and him.
And I realize he's got me
trained really, really well
to do my best to please
him and delight him,
which delighted me.
And there I was on the hook.
So that's one reason.
I think there's also
another reason, which
is super nerdy, which
is this C tactile fiber
thing, which is you
have these little nerve
endings in your skin.
And we know, of course,
that oxytocin is
released from parent and child.
We know this from
neuroimaging, et cetera.
We know oxytocin is released
from non-sexual romantic touch.
One of the things that is
very powerful for the release
of oxytocin-- very powerful--
is non-sexual grooming touch
among members of a species
or even across species.
So those pictures of monkeys
picking around in each other,
or people who insist on
popping things on one another,
or people who go to the
hairdresser or the barber
and they like touch.
It doesn't even
have to be massage--
massive oxytocin release.
Those data don't
get as much play
as all the data on
oxytocin and love.
It's called the love
hormone, but it's
basically a neurochemical
signaling system
for this interaction, feels
good, and is very much
of the present.
And I think that's an
important distinction
to make more broadly.
Is that dopamine is really
about the pursuit of all things
beyond the confines of our skin.
I'm going to get that thing.
I want that because it's
all about anticipation.
And when you have some
distance between yourself
and the thing that you
think will deliver,
whatever it is you
want, usually pleasure
in some form or another,
or excitement, whatever
your pleasure is or
combined, then you actually
have to mobilize.
And dopamine is the
precursor to adrenaline.
A lot of people don't know that.
Adrenaline is made
from dopamine.
It gets you into motion.
Then you have the
reward systems that
are more about what you have
from your skin surface inward.
So this is gentle
touch, holding hands,
and indeed stroking your dog.
Probably does that for you.
It activates these C
fibers, as they're called,
in your skin, which feed
right into these serotonin
and oxytocin system.
So the brain-- sounds a
little pop psychology-ish,
but it's a real thing, and
it exists in essentially all
mammalian species.
So I think a lot of us just
like dogs because they'll
let us just pet them all day.
Some people like to be touched
a little bit more or less,
even when they trust is all--
it's this consensual,
age appropriate, context
appropriate-- in this
case, species appropriate.
Those are the conditions,
very important.
When I was a kid, I had--
I don't know why.
My sister is in the audience.
I don't why she decided to
do this in the first place,
but I loved having
my face done--
pet like that.
I still like it,
but don't try it
because she's the only one--
she can't do it anymore even.
So we all have these
things that feel good,
and I think it feels
good because it
releases these chemicals.
And these are ancient systems--
ancient, ancient systems that
we all have, and I think dogs
let us do that.
And cats toy with
us with this one.
Because there are those
cats that let you pet them,
but most of the time
they're doing it to you,
and then they withdraw.
And I don't know many
dogs that do that.
So I think people, I'm going
to answer the question finally.
I think dogs we love them
so much because they let
us pet them as much as we want.
And cats play this
very diabolical game
that's a lot more like
human relationships.
[LAUGHTER]
How can night owls best
function in a society
made for morning birds?
Can you change your
chronotype or do us night
owls just have to suffer?
OK.
Well, as a former
night owl, I used
to work long hours in the lab.
I still work long hours
but less in the lab.
Just so happens that's
the way the career goes.
I'd put tinfoil on the windows.
I would lock the doors.
I'd blast the music, and I would
stay there over the holidays,
until I had to go home just
for the holiday events,
and my clock would drift.
So I became a night owl, and
then my clock would flip,
and everyone was gone.
Your mind gets really
tweaked when you're not
interacting with anybody.
By the way, seeing faces
in the morning and seeing
faces at some point
during the day
once you're ready to face
the day, very important
for mental health.
This is something I wish
more people knew about.
It also-- and here,
I'm not trying
to evoke any sentimentality.
But when you think about
people who just are clearly
not doing well, whether
or not they have shelter
or not-- it's how often do
we actually make direct eye
contact nowadays?
It's not very often.
So eye contact is important,
but I've also shifted
to being a morning person.
So here's the thing-- if you
are a true night owl, that
means that your circadian clock,
meaning the genes that control
the area of your brain
and your hypothalamus that
controls wake-sleep cycles,
is fundamentally different.
Very unlikely you'll
become a morning person
without being a kind of
angry morning person.
So you can use that argument,
and you can cite me.
However, as we get
older, it is true
that the amount of slow
wave sleep to REM sleep
tends to change,
and we can do better
on shorter bouts
of sleep, mostly
because we're getting less
rapid eye movement sleep.
And even if we try, we can't.
Those people would
probably be better off
sticking to a limited
amount of sleep at night,
and then getting a short nap.
The rule of naps is
nap if you want to.
Don't if you don't want,
but not if it interferes
with your nighttime sleep.
And if you can't nap, do some
sort of non-sleep deep breaths
or NSDRs.
I refer to it as
non-sleep depressed.
So you can probably shift
your clock by anywhere
from two to eight hours, and
that's true for lag as well.
Light is going to
be the best way,
but if you really
want to shift, you're
going to have to stack
the big three or four.
Light-- so get light when
you want to be awake.
Temperature-- you have to
increase your body temperature
to wake up.
You have to decrease body
temperature to go to sleep.
Keep in mind if you get into
an ice bath or cold shower,
you get very, very
cold, but then
what happens it's like putting
an ice pack on the thermostat.
Your body temperature goes up.
Remember, thermogenesis--
that's the warming of the body
in response to cold.
Of course, if you stay in a long
time, you'll get crispy cold.
You'll turn into a popsicle.
But the idea is that if
you take a cold shower,
and you get some bright light,
and you get some exercise,
and you drink some caffeine,
you can train your system
to expect that at a
certain time of day--
and you'll want to go to sleep
a little bit earlier or much
earlier, and you'll want to wake
up when you stack those things.
But that also means not taking
caffeine and cold showers
and doing exercise
late at night,
so it's going to take some work.
But those are the big four.
It's going to be light.
It's the most
powerful way to shift.
More light, awake.
Less light, asleep.
Temperature increase, awake.
Temperature decrease, asleep.
Food is the other one.
Eating-- you can force
yourself to eat breakfast,
even if you're not
a breakfast eater.
This works when you travel too.
Just get on to the
local meal schedule.
Because you have a clock system
in your gut, believe it or not.
You want to synchronize
that with your brain.
And then activity-- getting
some sort of exercise.
But it takes a little bit
of work, but you can do it.
You can definitely do it.
If you're nocturnal,
that's weird,
unless it's because of
your work, in which case
there are tools for shift
work that we've put out there
on the podcast.
Your podcasts has
been a wild success.
How do you see it growing
over the next few years?
Honestly, I try in
the tunnel of lack
of understanding and
awareness about what's
happening with all this.
I really do.
Lex suggested we do the podcast.
That's a true story of doing it.
I still really do
feel very much like I
did when I was a little kid.
I'm just going to keep
trying to learn and share.
I'd love for people
to share the tools.
I don't want credit for them.
If people credit us, great.
But if you think about it--
most of what we talk about
are not things that you buy.
These are tools that, again,
work the first time every time.
I always say
behavioral tools first,
then nutrition, supplementation.
And then for some people,
prescription drugs
or some of these more
experimental drugs make sense.
For some people it doesn't.
For instance, I don't think kids
should be doing psychedelics.
I mean, childhood is enough
of a psychedelic experience
in and of itself.
But I had an amazing clinician--
he's actually a triple-board
certified psychiatrist
neurologist at Stanford Nolan
Williams on the podcast--
and he talked about even the
use of ibogaine and MDMA,
even in some younger
populations but again,
with therapeutic oversight.
It blew my mind.
I also didn't know this--
that MDMA I thought was toxic.
Please don't just take
it off the street,
but if you're interested
in clinical trials,
there are great clinical
trials happening through maps,
and you can look at
Nolan's website as well.
Most of the knowledge
about the effects of MDMA
is from the LDS community
because they volunteered
for these studies because it's
not on the banned substance
list.
And so there's a
lot of knowledge,
and they don't tend to-- or
they don't use other substances,
like alcohol and
marijuana and cocaine.
So much of what we know
about the effects of MDMA
on the body and brain
is from that community.
Other communities too as well.
So what are we going
to do with the podcast?
Well, every Monday I'm going
to keep putting out episodes,
until they put me in that
grave with the thing.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It is a labor of love,
and it's a lot of fun.
And we're just always trying
to make them better, clearer.
Somehow they're not
getting shorter.
I always tell Rob-- this one
is going to be 90 minutes.
And he's like, yeah.
I'll believe it when I see it.
I think for me one
thing that has brought
that's really wonderful
is the opportunity
to learn from people
in other domains
that are far better
at putting information
and things into the world.
So I've been-- I hope he
doesn't mind me saying this.
I've been very blessed--
I've become really good
friends with Rick Rubin, who's
been really helpful to me.
He has an amazing book
on creativity coming out
that's not a plug for the
book, although I guess
I just accidentally did it.
But Rick of course,
is like producing.
Created all this amazing music.
Everything from like Run-DMC,
Beastie Boys, Slayer,
Johnny Cash, everything.
Just amazing.
And one of the things that
he's been impressing on me
is that it's very
important to stay focused
on the process of
what you're doing
and to really not get into too
much of how that's landing.
So I do like to hear when
things are not clear.
That's really helpful to me.
I do like to hear suggestions
about great people
to bring on the podcast.
I love criticism
most of the time.
I try my-- it's hard
sometimes, but I really
try and just absorb
it for what it is.
But I love that aspect
of interacting in this,
even though this is very
fairly unidirectional.
Hopefully, there'll be more
opportunities for dialoguing
and learning what's out there.
My real hope is that
practitioners will
start to incorporate things.
And again, it's not about me.
I'm gleaning from fields and
discoveries of other people
and trying to thread
across fields.
So that's why I see the podcast
going just more of the same,
more of the same, more of
the same but a lot more
and more topics as best
we can-- lots of guests.
And we actually have an
episode with Rick coming out
at some point about
creativity, which
I think is one of the
more interesting aspects
of our being, so watch for that.
What is a stress inoculation
protocol for workplace anxiety
(speaking)?
Does the principle of staying
calm under high adrenaline
state-- yeah, definitely.
I think if you were to
pick some sort of practice
that you could do
privately and safely--
again, how cold should
you make the water?
Cold enough that it's
really uncomfortable
and you really,
really want to get out
but you can safely stay in.
And that's why we never say
40 degrees because you can't
kill yourself with cold water.
It's just hard to do.
You have to get really, really
cold before you kill yourself.
And open bodies of
water aren't good.
Actually, I told my
friend Samer Hattar.
He's the director of
chronobiology unit
at the National Institutes
of mental health.
He came on the podcast.
Got him really-- he's
great about all the stuff
on light and sleep.
Taught me a lot of
that over the years.
We're good friends.
I told him about the
cold water thing,
and he got into some river in
Bethesda and almost drowned.
And Sam right now-- he has
a story about how he almost
drowned, and what he was--
and he thought about a paper
he wanted to write while
he was almost drowning.
So just be careful-- open bodies
of water, that kind of thing.
But I think you can quickly
see within about a week or so
of doing some sort of
deliberate adrenaline release.
It could be cyclic
hyperventilation,
25 hyperventilated breaths
with a short breath hold,
repeat, done two or three times.
We have good data to
support that in the lab.
You see massive shifts in
people's baseline level.
You become a little
bit more like Costello.
You really do.
And the way to think about it
is, if you are more on a seesaw
then on the continuum, you get
better at loosening that hinge
and controlling that hinge.
Or you can imagine moving
up and down that seesaw
a little bit more easily.
And then of course, you
have to place yourself
into the environment.
You have to test yourself
in that environment,
and some people will do
Toastmasters and things
like that, and it can work.
My way-- I don't know if
it works for everybody.
My way is just start talking.
Don't stop.
I can't feel the stress.
What do you think will
be the next hot topic/new
trend in the field of
neuroscience behavioral
therapeutics?
Ooh, I like that because I have
a lot of opinions about that.
First of all, I do
not think it's going
to be brain machine interface.
My good friend, Eddie Chang, who
I've known since we were nine,
he came on the podcast.
He works on epilepsy.
He's a chair of neurosurgery.
We had a bird club when we
were kids at two members.
You had to know the names
of all the talking birds,
and then you had to know
which one was the best talker,
and it's the minor bird.
And of course, no
one wanted to join.
No one even took the test.
But he became a neurosurgeon and
does brain machine interface.
He's doing truly incredible
work getting people
with locked in syndrome to
speak through a device implanted
under the skull.
They just think what
they want to say.
These are people who
haven't moved or shared
a word with anybody, and
they're now communicating,
but here's what's
really cool and--
he has also realized that
facial expression is a lot.
It's one thing to
see on a screen what
somebody in a chair or a
hospital bed is thinking.
That's wonderful,
but facial expression
is such a rich part of this.
So this is a really
good use of AI.
He's now created very
realistic iPad images
of that person's face,
and so they're actually
speaking the words.
And people form a
deep relationship
to the person who's right
next to their avatar,
so that's a positive
use, I think, of avatars,
and Eddie is doing amazing work.
That kind of work-- a brain
machine interface neural link,
et cetera, I think is going
to be very useful and popular
in the realm of therapeutics
for Parkinson's, movement
disorders, epilepsy,
locked-in syndrome, et cetera.
I think we are many, many, many
decades from chip implantation
into the brain for things
like enhancing memory,
and frankly I wouldn't want it.
Not because I wouldn't
want to enhance my memory,
but because of what
I said earlier.
Is that the nervous system has
a certain amount of real estate,
and you don't want to make
that real estate very lopsided.
And so I think we're going to
see something very different
in the next 10, 20
years, and I hope, hope,
hope this carries over
to younger populations.
I think we're going
to hopefully start
learning about our nervous
system and what it can do.
And the fact that we have these
pre-existing circuits in us
that we can learn
to leverage that
work first time every time.
So I'm strongly
biased in my answer,
but I think that it still
remains an open question,
for instance, whether or not
people could require less
perhaps or no medication
for certain things.
And I say certain things
because for conditions
like schizophrenia, bipolar
in particular medication,
OCD has proved very effective.
But then there are
a whole other set
of conditions like
depression and anxiety
for which behavioral
tools really work,
but most people just don't
even know they exist.
So that's my hope, and again,
the therapeutic community
could try and expand
their toolkit.
I also think we're
starting to see
a blurring of the lines between
different fields of psychology,
so it's no longer
psychoanalytic versus
cognitive behavioral
versus dialectic
versus EMDR versus hypnosis.
That it's all going
to be governed
by some central principles.
All those camps-- it's
just silly frankly to me.
It makes sense academically
why those came to be,
but in neuroscience
we had the same thing.
You used to have to pick.
It was like a John Hughes
film from the '80s.
Are you going to be a jock
or a punker or a popular kid.
Now, it's not like that,
and half this audience
is looking at me like,
what are you talking about?
And that's exactly the point.
Which is that I'll
never forget I grew up
in the skateboard thing.
The first time I saw someone
wearing skateboarding shoes,
I was like, damn.
They skateboard.
And they're like, no.
They just-- people are
just wearing this stuff.
So well, you start to realize
it's all blended together,
which is great.
And in the field
of neuroscience,
you used to have to pick.
Are you an anatomist
or a physiologist?
Are you into neural computation?
Now, your lab has to do it all,
or you collaborate with people.
Those divisions
have really melted
because people are
interested in questions,
and they're
interested in answers.
And don't get me started,
but the careerism
of the requirement
for everyone to have
their own independent
laboratory and say this
is my mission, that is one of
the worst things about science.
Because everything we know
says that collaboration
collaboration, collaboration,
leads to faster progress.
And I'm not going to take on
the whole academic system.
It's been very
good to me, but I'd
like to see a blurring
of the boundaries.
It used to be that
labs weren't-- here,
I'm really guilty, Huberman lab.
But it used to be that labs were
named after the problem they
worked on.
Vision Lab, Stress
Lab, Happiness Lab.
I like that quite
a bit more, but I
screwed up and called this
whole thing the Huberman Lab.
[LAUGHTER]
You have had a number
of performance interests
and fitness experts
on your show.
What changes have you made
to your fitness protocol,
including nutrition?
Oh.
Yeah.
Well, I'm an omnivore,
so I like those things
they call carbohydrates, and
I eat them in moderation.
And so I've never really been
too extreme about any of this,
or the fasting thing,
although I do just--
I'm not very hungry
in the morning.
That's also because I like
to eat a lot at night.
I wake up not that hungry.
So what have I changed?
Well, in terms of
the fitness stuff,
I've definitely
started to incorporate
more nasal breathing when I do
cardiovascular work because it
has eliminated any
sleep apnea I had.
And sleep apnea is
very, very bad--
very, very bad.
I wish I could say
snoring was no big deal,
but we know based on work at the
Stanford Sleep Lab, Penn Sleep
Lab, other sleep labs that
people who have sleep apnea
are really in for trouble
for a number of reasons.
So you want to learn
to be a nasal breather,
and if-- some people
will tape their mouth
shut with medical tape
when they go to sleep.
Other people will just start
doing cardiovascular work,
keeping their mouth closed.
And that requires that
you not go too intensely,
but it does create a dilation
of the nasal passages.
Those sinuses can dilate.
So I've definitely done that.
And at the end of
training, I try and do
a one-minute or
three-minute decompress.
Not immediately look
at my phone to learn
to shift from high
intensity thinking
and to lower intensity thinking
and shift throughout the day.
Task switching,
I think, is going
to be a big area of science
and neuroscience in general.
We still don't know
how to task switch
well-- how to shift the
mind from focus to defocus
and back again.
That's something
that-- by the way,
this is, I think a rich
opportunity for people
to develop tools.
We don't know a lot about that.
We got too caught up
on consciousness flow
and free will.
And that stuff is great, but
as you can tell, I like tools.
I like physiology.
I like the things that
work in my lifetime
and that we can figure out
and agree upon in my lifetime.
Let's see.
Got it.
And I'm told that
this final question--
when they put the clock
up here earlier too,
they said we're going to
run it for 60 minutes.
My first question was,
where's the snooze button?
So I'm going to keep
going, but I think
they're going to hold me to it.
And I know, people, this
is New York after all.
There are other
fun things to do.
For things that take
a long time-- career,
pursuing a degree--
is there a right way to know
that we're on the right path?
Is there a way to know
we're on the right path?
Thank you for that question.
I get asked this a
lot, and gosh, there's
so much information out there.
So much information about this.
We don't yet have a
gauge of whether or not
we're in too much
stress or not, but there
is one tool that's used in
the free diving community
and in other
communities that you
can use as a thermometer of
how well you're functioning.
And some of you may know
it already, and if you do,
forgive me.
It's this carbon
dioxide tolerance test.
So why am I answering
this question this way?
Well, I like to start
with actionable tools.
If, for instance, you were to
just take three or four breaths
and then take a big
deep breath and then
do a very slow
controlled exhale--
could be through your nose
or through your mouth.
Ideally, through your nose.
And you're trying to make that
exhale as long as possible,
until your lungs are
empty, and you time that.
That's called the carbon
dioxide discard rate
or the exhale discard rate.
And it tells you how well you're
controlling your diaphragm
using something called
the phrenic nerve.
It also tells you how well
you're managing carbon dioxide
and how well you're
managing stress.
And if you're very
stressed, that number
will be very, very short.
And I'm not talking
about how long
you can sit with lungs empty.
I'm talking about an honest
appraisal of how long
you can control that exhale for.
And if it's anywhere
from 0 to 20 seconds,
your stress level is high.
And if it's from 20 to 40
seconds, it's moderate.
And longer than 40
seconds means you
have good control over
your carbon dioxide system,
more or less.
Now, these are averages,
and guess what?
Has nothing to do with
fitness, and also, it
has nothing to do with you per
se because if you do this when
you first wake up after
a good night's sleep,
you'll have a long discard rate.
If you do this after
running, you'll
have a short discard rate.
You're not out of breath.
You're just not managing
the system very well.
So you can touch into this
every once in a while as a blood
pressure reading type thing.
This is very back of the
envelope it's not perfect,
but it works well enough
that alongside things
like resting heart rate, heart
rate variability, et cetera,
you can get a window into how
well you're managing stress.
Why am I answering
this question this way?
Well, this is
something I recommend
doing every once in
a while, especially
if you are in a period of a
career or any kind of pursuit
where you are feeling
like you're grinding.
I think once your carbon dioxide
discard rate starts to really
get shorter and shorter,
you're having trouble sleeping,
I think it's time to focus on
re-establishing that buoyancy
to your nervous system
because then and only then can
you make good judgments
about whether or not
you're in the right
trajectory for you.
Now, in terms of the larger
psychological themes,
are you doing something that
brings you meaning or not?
That gets into some
complicated territory.
We're very good at assigning
meaning retrospectively,
and saying, well, that
was a good experience
because we had it, and we
learned from it, et cetera.
But I think most people
would like to avoid things
that they can only
look back on and say,
it was useful because I
learned something from it.
And for that, I'll
just give the default,
but I think, at least
to me, accurate answer,
which is the more
often that you can
tap into that feeling of
excitement and delight
in your work, even
if from small things
or from surprising things, or
from the social interactions
that you're able to
glean from that work,
the longer and better you're
going to be able to pursue
that line of work.
For me is in graduate
school, I was very isolated.
I worked alone in the lab.
Maybe it was because
of the tin foil
I put on the walls
or the windows.
I don't know.
In fact, my graduate
advisor's one complaint
was that I seemed unfriendly.
I wasn't unfriendly.
I was just busy, but I got
to be very good friends
with the janitorial
staff because they
were the only one around
at the time I was working--
were a few other people.
And those small
interactions actually became
very significant to me and
became sources of brief--
but to me, at
least, at the time,
meaningful social exchange.
And of course,
eventually, I made friends
and had relationships of
other kinds and things
that were healthy as well.
But I think learning to tap into
this love of what you're doing
is sometimes hard, but
you have to look for it.
It's an active process,
and I'll default
to the work and the podcast
that's coming with Rick Rubin.
And he is a lot of what he talks
about in terms of creativity.
Is about accessing
what he and others have
talked about as the source.
If that is an abstract,
I don't know what is.
But the source is this
ability to see yourself
as more of a portal for
getting certain things done
in the world than
being so careerist
and focused on whether or
not outcomes are really
matching what you need.
It involves some
mental flexibility,
and of course, it's OK
to pivot back and forth.
But we can only
access this feeling
of delight and joy
and this feeling
that we're somehow connected to
some larger theme, aka meaning,
I think, when we are able to be
calm enough and not so focused.
But in order to
get anything done,
we have to be hyper focused,
and that brings me back
to the basic principle of
today's whole discussion, which
is that it's not
about landing yourself
in a state of focus
motivation and drive
or in a state of deep sleep.
Certainly, not in a coma.
It's about being able to move up
and down the various continuums
that allow you to access
focus and real gas
pedal down to the floor
kind of thinking and action
but then also deliberately
back off transition
to periods of rest.
And the real key is for
you to feel like you're
in the driver's seat.
If we know anything from
the last 100-plus years
of psychology and
neuroscience literature,
it's that if an
animal or a person
feels that they are in control
of the physiological process
within them, and they know
they can get themselves
out, some way somehow at some
point and back into a state
that they want somehow,
some way, at some point,
well, then, all the language
around meaning and happiness
and delight starts to emerge.
So learn to move along
those continuums.
Learn to do it
deliberately, and I wish you
the very best of luck in it.
I know it works.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thanks so much for coming out.
[APPLAUSE]
I really appreciate
it and grateful
to our sponsors, of course.
Thank you and to all
of you for your time.
I know there's a lot
to do in the city,
and I hope everyone enjoys it.
And of course, I'd be
remiss if I didn't say,
thank you for your
interest in science.
[CHEERS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]